[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing professor sybil
trelawny albus dumbledore severus snape
hogsmeade pub
and the fabled prophecy more
specifically we're going to be taking a
look at trelawney's prediction
and discussing why she was taken
seriously
the thing is sybil trelawny despite
having a proven track record of
predicting things
does not have a particularly good
reputation and that is mainly because
divination as an area of magic is not
particularly well received
amongst the wizarding population
divination is an elective course
taught at hogwarts from third year
onwards in essence
it's essentially the art of predicting
the future there are various ways to
achieve this
and methods include but are not limited
to
tea leaves fire omens crystal balls paul
mystery
cartomancy astrology and dream
interpretations
despite divinations proven legitimacy
it is often the target of considerable
scrutiny even by some of the brightest
witches and wizards
mcgonagall once described it as one of
the most imprecise branches of magic
and hermione outwardly disrespected
trolloni during one of her divination
lessons
a testament to her perception of it as a
field of magic
in fact even dumbledore had his qualms
with divination
despite recognizing it as a legitimate
field of magic
i think that he knew that it was real
but did not necessarily believe
that it could be achieved by many people
a skill reserved for a highly
specialized and select few in fact
when dumbledore interviewed trolloni for
her position at hogwarts
he was initially quite unimpressed on a
cold wet night
16 years ago in a room above the bar the
hogs head in
i had gone there to see an applicant for
the post of divination teacher
though it was against my inclination to
allow the subject of divination
to continue at all the applicant however
was the great great granddaughter
of a very famous very gifted seer and i
thought it common politeness to meet her
i was disappointed it seemed to me that
she had not a trace of the gift herself
i told her courteously i hope that i did
not think she would be suitable for the
post
i turned to leave but of course just as
he turned to leave
civil traulani entered into a deep
trance foretelling the fabled
prophecy the same prophecy that would
flip the wizarding world
upside down the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord approaches
born to those who have thrice defied him
born as the seventh month dies
and the dark lord will mark him as his
equal but he will have power the dark
lord knows not
and either must die at the end of the
other for neither can live while the
other survives
the one with the power to vanquish the
dark lord will be born as the seventh
month dies
and what's interesting about sybil to
learning telling this particular
prophecy
is that it seemingly legitimized her
ability to predict the future
in dumbledore's mind it solidified her
ability to practice
what she preached however my issue with
this
is that if the events she foretold
hadn't yet occurred
how could her prediction be valid how
could this have changed his perception
of her
couldn't she be making it up she had
every reason
to fake her ability to tell the future
particularly as it came at the end of an
awful interview
even snape who overheard a portion of
her prophecy
took it at face value and accepted that
it was in fact
valid so why why did people listen
to trelawney's first prophecy i think
that it's for a couple of reasons
reason number one is that trelloni came
from a long line of
validated seers in fact one of our
ancestors was cassandra celani
of which he would become famous for her
ability to predict the future
however i seriously doubt that
trelloni's heritage alone
was enough to convince dumbledore
especially with how the interview was
going
so i think that this second reason is
also important
in dumbledore's pensive memory the
following is revealed about trelawney's
prediction
but when sibyl trolloni spoke it was not
in her usual
ethereal mystic voice but in the harsh
hoarse tones harry had heard her use
once before
the one with the power to vanquish the
dark lord approaches
this reveals that trelawny was not just
spouting off nonsense
she was in a legitimate trance a trance
that was clearly convincing enough to
validate her predictions
dumbledore and snape are no fools they
are highly perceptive individuals
and they knew exactly what was happening
and that's it for this video
did you guys ever wonder why trelawny
was taken seriously the first time
around
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
your aura is pulsing are you in the
[Music]
beyond